what's going on guys this is rob and
before you ask don't worry i will let
you all see my not very beautiful face
again we've just been getting bombarded
with like snow and ice and it's just
more convenient to record from home so
word has reached my ears and by this i
mean i was sent a twitter dm uh then
apparently there's a theory floating
around out there that this person in
doctor strange two
is not superior iron man or captain
marvel who basically is being played by
monica and or maria rambo that instead
it's a variant of kang the conqueror who
hasn't become a bad guy yet now my
thought on this is that okay if they're
gonna do that
then one that would kind of
overcomplicate things especially because
if they were to do that it would most
likely be iron lad and two
what would be the point okay so we're
gonna answer that second question here
in a minute here's the explanation on
iron lab and honestly i'm gonna give you
guys an example outside of comics
because if i try to explain iron lad
from marvel comics it would be
ridiculous because the whole
relationship between iron lad and
immortus uh you guys know him as he who
remains and kane the conqueror are
basically just it's the most overly
complicated and convoluted unnecessarily
just it's the biggest pain in the ass
ever in like marvel comics so here's the
idea let's say you're 50 years old right
because i don't know how old you are but
let's say you're 50 years old and let's
say that you're a professional thief and
let's say you've somehow discovered the
ability to travel back in time now let's
say that when you were 20 years old that
you were presented with two options and
that making either one of these choices
would irrevocably change your life you'd
be given the option to travel the world
or to go to college now the choice you
made at 20 years old was to travel the
world which in turn led you down the
path of becoming a thief and so in order
to ensure that you do follow that path
you at 50 years old with the ability to
time travel go back to when you're 20
years old and tell your 20 year old self
i need you to make sure that you travel
the world when you're given the
opportunity to do that instead of going
to college and when your 20 year old
self asks why you say because when you
travel the world you'll go through a
whole bunch of experiences and then
you'll basically become me a
professional thief at 50 years old the
kicker is that your 20 year old self
says absolutely not i do not want to
become a professional thief i do i do
not want to do that and so your 20 year
old self does everything they can to
make sure that they don't become you the
funny thing is no matter what your 20
year old self does they will inevitably
become you right hence the reason why
you went back in time in the first place
to make sure they become you
so here's the thing that's that's the
relationship between king the conqueror
and basically iron lad they came to
conquer travel back in time met his
younger self and then said hey i need
you to make sure that you do the things
you're supposed to do in order to become
me and his younger self said no i don't
want to do that and then he actually
ended up becoming a superhero instead of
a super villain and then basically does
everything he can not to become kane the
conqueror that's the whole idea behind
there now here's the issue with that if
they threw that into the mcu it's going
to confuse the hell out of the entire
movie-going audience because it already
seems like there's just so much
happening in in doctor strange two
already if they add in a subplot this is
actually king the conqueror before he
becomes a bad guy right then you have to
answer the question of like motivation
and all that kind of stuff plus it's
also predicated on the assumption that
people were watching loki and one of the
things that kevin foggy has come out and
said is that watching the tv shows are
not necessary in order to understand
what's going on in the movie line of
things it helps but it's not required so
if they're going to invoke a variant of
king the conqueror in doctor strange too
then it would have to effectively be
something self-contained and relies on
nothing more than the average person's
knowledge that king is the next big
villain
here's how i think they do that and i
think it's you know i'm not going to say
it's a genius thing and in fact this
theory is probably so far-fetched that
it's just it's never going to happen but
as you guys know when it comes to theory
crafting i don't care if i'm right or
wrong so here's the thing about this
right let's imagine for example that
this this whole movie takes place right
that you have like the the events that
unfold however it is they unfold maybe a
store mamu who's manipulating scarlet
witch maybe it really is just wanda who
flipped
whatever the case is right it's just
this great big huge threat now we do
know just based on loki right just using
that little bit of information one we
know that kane the conqueror is the main
bad guy and we also know the multiverse
is back right whether or not you saw
loki is irrelevant in relation to that
doctor strange too is literally the
multiverse of madness and what will
likely be explained over the course of
that movie even if they don't
necessarily directly invoke loki is that
the multiverse is basically growing now
the multiverse is essentially out of
control the events as they transpired in
loki are generally known to the movie
going audience even if the finer details
are not but basically they would walk
away or go into the movie with that
information the multiverse is back and
it's spiraling out of control why it's
happening they may not know they simply
just know that it is and so this is when
you basically end up having like the
formation of the illuminati as it was
brought together by this variant of king
the conqueror right this this however it
is they want to spend this guy and so
what this does is it gives us the
illuminati as a group of multiversal
beings who whatever their motivation
happens to be it doesn't really matter
for this theory but whatever their
motivation happens to be have come
together in order to quell the threat of
whatever it is that's threatening the
multiverse scarlet witch dormammu
combination of both right doctor strange
gets involved they're like hey cool
thanks you know stephen strange here are
the things that we have to do in order
to win and doctor strange basically
helps them right he working alongside
the illuminati as well as any other
beings that he comes across right so
like america chavez so on and so forth
that they all basically end up coming
out on top right basically like the day
is saved
now you get to the end of the movie
possibly even a post-credits scene right
where you get to the end of the movie
and this king variant
right meets with the rest of the
illuminati and
basically tells them like
the threat's been defeated right like
the day has been saved you know the path
is clear
now
the rest of the illuminati basically
deactivate their image inducers
and they're not the illuminati the
illuminati never existed and doctor
strange too right it was a ruse the
illuminati is the council of kings and
the reason why this was done is because
despite what kang is capable of being
able to travel the multiverse and all
kinds of cool stuff like that kang does
not have the power to defeat somebody
like dormammu or even scarlet witch they
don't have the power to do that right he
does not have the ability to do that the
reason being because king the conqueror
is a technological guy he's not a
magical guy right he's a guy that
basically uses technology to travel
around the multiverse so he's got like
super advanced weapons and different
things like that but i have a hard time
believing that a guy running up on
dormammu with like you know a phaser gun
or like photon torpedoes is somehow
going to be able to defeat that guy and
so because of that what king needed is
somebody who is comparable to dormammu
in terms of power or someone who's
overcome dormammu in the past possibly
even has the ability to defeat the
scarlet witch basically a concerted
effort among magical beings and what you
basically end up realizing is that the
entire events of doctor strange two
right not necessarily like scarlet witch
losing their mind but like doctor
strange stepping in the battle that
unfolded the defeat of like dormammu
scarlet witch whatever it is it was all
being manipulated behind the scenes by
king the conqueror in order to remove an
obstacle from his path in order to
ensure that like if it really is
dormammu and the return of the
multiverse means all these different
variants of wanda maximoff the scarlet
witch who can now be controlled or
possessed by dormammu in order to seize
control of those universes and expand
that sphere of influence that this
expansion can basically be stopped and
it can ensure that the council of kings
can basically rule the multiverse now
obviously there's a million holes in
this theory but here's the reason why
assuming those holes can be patched
here's a reason why i think that would
work the reason being because of the
fact that what it does is it introduces
king the conqueror it gives us our first
look at king the conqueror in doctor
strange 2 which would make the most
sense given the fact that king is a
multiversal being that king has the
desire to conquer the multiverse that he
who remains from loki told us that it
wasn't just one kang doing it it was a
group of kings it was multiple kings so
basically the council of kings so it
gives us that perspective and it also
does not make king the main overarching
villain of the movie it doesn't give us
so much about his character what it does
is it gives us just enough to realize
how dangerous this guy is that the
danger of kane the conqueror does not
lie in his desire to get the infinity
stones and blink out half the life in
the universe for reasons that makes
sense to no one but himself that the the
danger of kang relies on the fact that
one you never know if it's king that
you're dealing with and two the guy
tricked the multiverse the guy literally
duped the multiverse into essentially
fighting a war for him and then winning
that war for him and then clearing the
path for him to conquer the multiverse
all the while the heroes being
blissfully unaware of that fact that's
the danger of king that is this like
literally you would walk away from that
like holy cow like the thought that i
would have coming out of that is
what hope do these heroes have right
like they're used to fighting like the
chitauri coming from space or loki who's
funny but kind of a dick and can like
trick people from time to time on like a
small level but fighting a guy who can
trick the multiverse without anybody
being aware of the fact that he is doing
that that's a whole different beast
that's a whole different level of
deception right so let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
i know this video is shorter than most
of the videos that we make but let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section right because here's
the thing even if this this theory
doesn't come to fruition and honestly i
don't care whether it does or not what i
think this would do is really give us a
great depiction of just how dangerous
kane can be and how far his reach is and
how capable the council of kangs are
right i think it would just be i think
it would be pretty badass i think it'd
be pretty amazing but let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace